my name is Eric solitaire I'm a
registered guide outfitter and I operate
two lodges in Alaska with my wife Martha
May we're gonna go ahead and try a
little bit longer distance here and see
if we can be comfortable at a 35 yard
range holes are my same bullseye hey
Sean ya been practisin up here see if I
can't catch me a bear with the bow the
state of Alaska is encouraging sportsmen
to go out and harvest brown bears and
black bears so that they don't predate
upon the moose calves individual bears
can kill an astonishingly large number
of moose calves in a very short period
and that really put the hurt on the
moose population I'm gonna throw my
stuff together if you throw a little
food together for me
how many days how many days worth of
food oh I'd say if I don't catch
anything in two days I'll come home
what's challenging about this hunt is
that you're not shooting with the rifle
anymore you're shooting with a bow so
you got to get closer you got to
practice a lot more it's totally
different you got to be comfortable with
the bow and confident which is hard to
be
well the fog lifted yeah actually it
burned all off so oh this is a lot nicer
than it was yesterday I I've seen all
kinds of planes flying around this
morning yeah let's go dump the stuff out
by the airstrip I got some extra arrows
and my pack and I got my frame pack and
a knife in a sleeping bag I got a tent
here comes Matt I was the weather on the
way over
beautiful good an awesome trip Thanks
load up and get going
oh you better be careful my bow now I
know how you pilots are all right guys
hopefully we'll be seeing you in a
couple of days all right y'all buckle in
back there I'm good to go
all right well Eric and mater gone doing
their hunting thing I'm gonna hold up
the fort here just day-to-day chores
taking care of fishing clients and
facilitating whatever needs to be done
you